في نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي اطلقت
الصين حمله لتطعيم كبار السن فيها والتي
يقول خبراء الصحه انها ضروريه للمساعده
على تجنب حدوث ازمه في قطاع الرعايه
الصحيه الان ثم س دراستان تدعماني اولئك
الذين يحثون الناس على التطعيم
الان رؤيه هذه الدراسات الكبيره تتحدث عن
الارتباط بين التطعيم وتكرار الاعراض
الطويله المدارس من المهم حقا ان نتمكن
الان على وجه اليقين من القول ان التطعيم
تكرار الاعراض الطويله المدى بالاضافه الى
الاعراض الاكثر خطوره من المرض الذي يظهر
في وقت مبكر بعد الاصابه
حلل دراسه البريطانيه نشرت نتائجها في
مجله كارديولوجيا
160 الف شخص خلال شهرين مارس و نوفمبر من
عام 2020 اي قبل ابتكاري لقاحات كورونا
ووجدت الدراسه ان اولئك الذين اصيبوا
بالمرض خلال تلك الفتره كانوا اكثر عرضه
للوفاه بمعدل يصل الى احدى 81 مره خلال
الاسابيع الثلاثه الاولى من الاصابه
لكنها وجدت ايضا ان الاشخاص كانوا اكثر
عرضه للاصابه بامراض القلب بعد 22 يوم من
التشخيص في السياق ذاته توصل دراسه اخرى
اعتمدت على مراقبه نحو الفيس شخص اجراها
باحثون امريكيون من جامعه الخدمات المنظمه
للعلوم الصحيه في ولايه ميريلاند الى ان
الاشخاص الذين لم يتلق تطعيما ظهرت لديهم
الاعراض لمده 28 يوم او اكثر بعد الاصابه
كما وجدت الدراسه الامريكيه ان 27% من
الاشخاص غير المطعمين الذين شملهم البحث
لديهم معدلات اعلى من الاعراض الطويله
المدى وتقول دراسه ان بعض المشاركين
اصيبوا بامراض لمده تصل الى سته اشهر بعد
اصابتهم بفيروس كورونا وقال علماء ان
نتائج الدراسه تؤكد فوائدا اللقاحات
وجرعات المعجزه لمنع سلالات جديده من
الفايروس لكن متى اسبابه للامل على الرغم
من ذلك
ان اعراض قرون الطويله تختفي بعد عام